tout le monde a réagi un j ai bien sûr
rachida dati a défoncé valérie pécresse
geoffroy didier marlène schiappa l'ice
cunti xavier bertrand
voilà la marine le pen bien sûr gilbert
collard et benoît qu'ils ont
ils ont défendu série b nasa moi je
trouve que la phrase est raciste enfin
quelques onces cautionne une pratique un
système raciste
je veux bien entend les arguments de
rokhaya diallo sur les groupes de parole
je veux bien qu'on adapte à des femmes
battues qui voudraient parler entre
elles de leurs problèmes sans être
dérangé par des hommes
mais les noirs ne sont pas les femmes
battues des blancs en france c'est pas
seulement forcément uniquement des
personnes noires ça peut être des
personnes de personnes ratio j'imagine
mais enfin ce sont les blancs qui sont
exclues parce que on entre dans un
système dans lequel on divise la
population en deux catégories les
dominants et les dominés et forcément
les dominants dans votre approche sont
toujours les blancs les deux minutes
mais nous le savons des femmes par
exemple qui peuvent être victimes de
sexisme l'homophobie peuvent peut-être
de petites couleurs simplement s'agit
d'un espace temporaire il s'agit
simplement pendant un temps comme comme
le principe des alcooliques anonymes
c'est à dire que pendant un temps on
parle de notre souffrance on parle de
notre douleur on essaie de trouver des
solutions on va réunir et après apporter
à l'ensemble des sociétés c'est à dire
que c'est pas une ségrégation définitifs
sont des gens qui temporairement se
disent qu'on va avoir un espace où on
peut respirer être tout simplement oui
montre nous mêmes mais ce n'est pas
définitif
nicolas pernikoff 1.046 riaz une
question d'accord qu elle vous rend pas
service quand même parce que de manière
à nous et je me sens pas je vous
embrasse les jeux sont pas hyper à
l'aise avec la formulation ne pose
problème mais le principe me dérange pas
qu'on aurait sciemment okaya ok mais là
soit on est content de se calmer quand
même on va pas les jeter dehors on va
pas leur interdire ces données c'est un
terrible aussi vous je comprends je
comprendrais formulation moi je serai
fort moi j'ai toujours défendues
principe de ces réunions c'est à dire qu
on dise on est dans un groupe on décide
par exemple il ya en france un groupe
qui s'appelle l'union des étudiants
juifs de france parce qu'à un moment
donné dans l'histoire les étudiants
juifs ont eu le temps de se réunir pour
parler de la problématique
ce qui n'empêche pas cette association
le giec de collaborer avec sos racisme
chercheur lutter contre toutes les
formes de racisme
donc il y avait parfois des moments on a
besoin de sérogroupe et cette terre
qu'il est peut être maladroit elle a mal
formulée mais je pense que le panama
l'ipaf n invalide pas le principe je
pense que l'eau et des collants mais on
connaissait que c'est une forme de
racisme
non parce que il s'agit là de leur
assisté priver quelqu'un de quelque
chose
imagine
quelques uns de ces noms vous dit on dit
souvent que les mots ont un sens
imaginez la même phrase où on prononce
non mais alors les noirs sont priés de
se taire ç'aurait ok couturier dit c'est
du racisme président lasana mais je
comprends ce que vous dites mais dans la
syntaxe dans les mots et on dit que les
montrent un sens étendu la formule à
l'usso s'est passé on peut pas comparer
rokhaya l'adie match peut pas dire que
le dos vincent s'est rassis ces deux
hommes se serrent la formulation est
problématique mais le principe n'est pas
un principe d'exclusion c'est à dire que
dans une société où les personnes des
personnes sont déjà discriminées
si elles se réunissent à paris l'a dit
leur discrimination ce n'est pas
l'exclusion des autres simplement la
réunion d'intérêt commun c'est à dire
que c'est comme si vous êtes un alcool
vous êtes alcoolique vous réunissez par
une mise l'alcoolique anonyme pour
parler de votre condition parce que
c'est pas facile d'en parler en dehors
de ce sac ça veut pas dire que vous
discriminer les personnes qui ne sont
pas alcooliques pourrais vous dire que
pendant un temps vous ayez trouvé des
solutions pour nous entraînons cependant
talent peut pas être frileux pour moi de
baignoire c'est sympa sensible s'il peut
être sensible mais ça veut dire que ça
veut pas dire que ces deux de tout temps
dans tous les espaces on les exclut ça
veut dire que temporairement
et ça veut dire que bien sûr que
benjamin vous ne pouvez pas comprendre
exactement ce que je ressens quand je
vis une discrimination évidemment est ce
que vous ne vivez pas c'est à dire que
non moi si je viens et je vous explique
des choses extrêmement personnelle par
rapport à la manière dont je dois
réfléchir
ah si je vais dans une émission et ce
qui est ma couleur de peau de fontain
etc
je sais qu'une personne noire va le
comprendre automatiquement alors que
vous et donc je fasse un chemin pour
voulait que c'est bien le chemin qu'ils
ont choisi supplément nationale a et on
n'a pas justement on organise ces
réunions pour ne pas avoir en plus à
prendre la charge de ce chemin pour vous
expliquer c'est le chemin je peux
l'expliquer ce soir d'ailleurs je le
fais ce soir sans aucun problème mais
peut être que demain j'aurai envie d'en
parler avec des gens qui vont comprendre
directement
disons que j'ai investir de l'énergie